trek tout ça est assez complexe assez
compliqué disons tout d'abord que c'est
un suffrage indirect absolument solide
en fait les partisans qui soit bon
républicain où qu'ils soient même
démocrate dans le fond il aimerait
beaucoup voté pour le candidat mais
entre les deux se trouvent les fameux
délégués les délégués se sont les gens
donc qui s'engage à voter pour le
candidat que les militants auront
choisies lors des conventions nationales
qu'elles soient démocrates ou
républicaines voyez c'est la même chose
aussi du côté démocrate donc là aussi
aura des délégués entre les deux et tout
cela donc va se décider en juillet
convention nationale du parti
c'est là qu'on m'a désigné
officiellement le candidat à la
présidence qui lui va choisir son
colistier c'est à dire le candidat à la
vice-présidence
on est au début de ce processus alors il
ya des primaires il ya des caucus quelle
est la différence
alors c'est très similaire le résultat
est le même sauf que la façon d'y
arriver est vraiment différent par
exemple les primaires c'est très
formelle s'est organisée par l'état pour
les démocrates et les républicains donc
on va voter
il ya une boîte de scrutin on se met
dans l'isoloir et on met ces petites
croix côtés du délégué qu'on veut
choisir
par contre pour les caucus comme ce soir
en iowa ce qui se passe c'est que ce
sont les assemblées populaires donc on
va dans un sous sol d'église dans une
école on se compte alors donné on ferme
les portes et on dit bon ben moi je vote
pour toi suivez moi donc il ya un groupe
qui va là un groupe cheyrou bio etc etc
et à la fin mais si tout se fait à main
levée et là on sait en fait qui le
gagnant ce soir là bon christian il
faisait allusion la y aura cette semaine
le new hampshire et semaine prochaine de
tout petit détail pourtant tous les yeux
sont tournés vers eux
parce que c'est quand même important ça
donne le temps exactement en fait parce
que ce sont les premiers états où ça se
passe et on le voit ça dit beaucoup
d'informations par exemple pour les
candidats on l'a vu ce soir déjà
peut-être un premier désistement
donc ça permet d'évaluer les cas les
chances de chaque candidat quelqu'un qui
n'arrive pas être dans les trois
premiers par exemple ce soir il aura
beaucoup de difficulté à convaincre les
donateurs de financer sa campagne pour
les autres états et pour les partisans
mais ils vont se dire bah tiens j'avais
choisi celui-là il n'a aucune chance de
gagner je vais aller avec un autre mais
est ce que il faut à falloir attendre
jusqu'à jusqu'à la fin donc jusqu'au
mont les conventions en juillet pour
vraiment connaître le vainqueur où on
aura une bonne idée
on aura probablement une bonne idée
avant parce que bon ce soir c'est l'iowa
donc on commence vraiment petit ensuite
la semaine prochaine ça va être le new
hampshire mais à partir du 15 mars là ce
sont les sous paul cruz des donc les
super mardi où on va avoir une douzaine
une quinzaine d'états qui vont se
prononcer en même temps et là c'est
souvent des états qui sont très populeux
donc vers la mi avril on devrait pas mal
fixé sur la suite des choses il peut y
avoir vraiment une surprise la toute fin
c'est rare mais ça se peut par exemple
lors des conventions des délégués
pourrait décider de changer complètement
de candidats y aussi les super délégués
qui sont les vedettes du parti qui ont
un poids vraiment important et ils ont
pouvoir de faire basculer la balance
c'est ce qui est arrivé par exemple en
2008 lorsqu'ils ont décidé de se mettre
en arrière de monsieur obama
plutôt que de madame clinton donc tout
est possible mais c'est plutôt rare
alors vous aurez réussi à nous faire
comprendre ricoh qu'elodie peur merci
beaucoup fréquenté